[Musica]
buonasera a tutti questa era il
campionato ultimo campionato del mondo
che si è svolto a settembre in bulgaria
sofia dove questa squadra la squadra
nazionale italiana di ginnastica ritmica
ha conquistato l'ultimo oro proprio in
questo esercizio funi e palle queste
ginnaste che vedete meravigliose sono
attualmente le ginnaste della squadra
nazionale e negli anni si sono
naturalmente avvicendate ma la loro
allenatrice è sempre la stessa ed
emanuela maccarani e l'allenatrice della
squadra nazionale italiana
dell'esercizio di insieme perché nella
ginnastica ritmica abbiamo due tipologie
esercizi individuali dove è una ginnasta
che compete e l'esercizio invece
d'insieme dove sono cinque ginnaste come
avete visto che contemporaneamente
lavorano in pedana scambiandosi gli
esercizi e facendo tante difficoltà
questa allenatrice e alla sua accento
72esima medaglia a livello
internazionale ed è là
e dell allenatrice questo a detta del
coni malagò proprio in persona più
medagliata d'italia e penso anche del
mondo e naturalmente questo percorso
e voi avete visto la fase finale no la
medaglia la medaglia d'oro il titolo di
campione del mondo
ma dietro vi assicuro che c'è tanto
lavoro tanto sacrificio da parte di
tutto lo staff tecnico e da parte delle
ginnaste che dall'età di 14 e 15 anni
vengono prelevate dalle loro famiglie
dalla loro società che fino a quel
momento le allenate e vanno quindi in un
centro dove lavoreranno insieme per anni
e dove lavoreranno per otto ore al
giorno e dove studieranno e dove
svolgeranno la loro vita d'ora in poi
loro dicono che non è un sacrificio
perché poi il momento in cui salgono sul
podio ti fa dimenticare tutto
e dal 2003 che questa squadra con le
ginnaste che si avvicendano negli anni
ottiene risultati e questo è l'ultimo
dei loro grandi risultati
e qui io sono in questo mondo da 40 anni
sono una grande appassionata di questo
sport è la mia vita tutta la mia vita
l'ho costruita proprio intorno a questo
sport e seguendo negli anni questi
grandi risultati
pur non avendo ancora una un incarico
federale
ho sempre pensato che non bastava
ottenere risultati nella parte tecnica
diciamo proprio dei risultati con le
competizioni ma bisognava affiancare
anche cominciare ad organizzarle le
competizioni e io sono sempre stata
un'appassionata di organizzazione di
eventi e ho iniziato quindi organizzando
campionati italiani ma non gli ho mai
organizzati con quelle poche cose magari
che servivano sempre organizzato molto
in grande e forse di te sei una mela un
megalomane
no perché ho sempre avuto dentro di me
forse anche magari non con grande
coscienza però l'idea di fare un giorno
qualcosa di veramente grande e quindi
organizzavo competizioni italiane in
sono riuscita ad entrare in impianti
dove finora la ginnastica ritmica povera
sconosciuta ginnastica ritmica non era
mai entrata tipo l'adriatic arena di
pesaro che lo chiamano il tempio del
basket il 105 stadium di rimini il pala
indoor di ancona dell'atletica leggera
ecco sono riuscite strada entrare in
questi ambienti ea organizzare
competizioni nazionali per un certo
punto detto beh è ora di organizzare
qualcosa per far gareggiare questa
squadra questa squadra in italia e farle
vedere perché se no bisognava andare
sempre all'estero per seguirle e così
finalmente ho chiesto alla federazione
di candidarsi per gareggiare la coppa
del mondo
una tappa di coppa del mondo e bruno
grandi che era presidente della
federazione internazionale riuscita a
darci a dare alla federazione italiana
perché la federazione italiana che deve
candidarsi per questi eventi riusciti
quindi a dare la la possibilità di
organizzare la tappa una tappa di coppa
del mondo e da qui siamo arrivati alla
undicesima edizione il prossimo anno
quindi organizziamo per l'undicesima
volta la tappa italiana questa tappa è
stata consegnata l'organizzazione è
stata consegnata dalla federazione al
comitato turismo e sport del comitato
organizzatore locale che io presiedo
formato dalla mia società all aurora
fano e aspes che un'azienda
municipalizzata di pesaro che fra
l'altro gestisce l'impianto
dell'adriatic arena dopo dieci anni
non mi sono accontentate da qui mi
ricollego al fantastico che per me è
stato reale ho detto beh dopo dieci anni
di coppa del mondo la coppa del mondo
sapete è un circuito no ci sono tante
tappe alla fine delle quali c'è una
classifica e ho detto beh dopo dieci
anni di coppa penso di essere in grado
con il mio comitato organizzatore di
organizzare anche un campionato del
mondo mai organizzato in italia finora
[Musica]
e così dal 30 di agosto al 3 settembre
del 2017 si è svolta il 35esimo
campionato del mondo di ginnastica
ritmica mai organizzato finora in italia
alla presenza di un pubblico enorme
proveniente da tutta italia e da tutto
il mondo e da qui un altro pezzo
mancante per far sì che questa squadra
avesse tutto quello che era necessario
per continuare nella loro attività e
finalmente la casa la casa delle
farfalle
questa è la squadra delle farfalle
l'avrete sentita e la casa quindi una
palestra dove potessero allenarsi in
maniera fissa e non come purtroppo
accadeva finora al pala banco desio di
desio questa era la loro sede finora noi
lavoriamo su pedane di ginnastica
ritmica di legno sono 200 pezzi di un
metro e 40 per un metro e quaranta che
vengono smontati ogni 15 giorni per fare
spazio al basket che doveva farle
partite immaginate in questi anni e poi
hanno dovuto cambiare impianti
palazzetti perché anche gli altri che
avevano vicine erano impegnate quindi
una vita difficilissima finalmente cioè
l'accademia internazionale di ginnastica
ritmica
grazie alla federazione ginnastica
italiana al coni e al comune di desio
naturalmente con l'insediamento del
nuovo presidente della federazione
ginnastica d'italia nel 2017 il cavalier
gherardo tecchi è stato inserito il
ruolo del team manager federale per ogni
sezione e io sono il team manager della
ginnastica ritmica italiana
il mio ruolo è un ruolo proprio che si
riconduce al titolo di oggi equilibrio
perché è proprio il morolo quello di
creare un equilibrio fra le varie parti
federale politico amministrativa
dirigenziale e la parte tecnica
io sono quella che cerca di realizzare
tutti i progetti di cui necessita la
sezione da la stesura del budget che per
cui dobbiamo poi attingere per svolgere
tutte le attività alla organizzazione di
tutti gli allenamenti di tutte le
categorie dalle allieve alle squadre
nazionali tutte le l'organizzazione di
tutte le trasferte di tutte le
competizioni internazionali e una
miriade di altre cose è quello che
soprattutto a cui tengo di più è creare
proprio un raccordo intorno a me
tra tutte le varie parti dobbiamo
parlare quindi tutti la stessa lingua
questo che riusciamo penso a fare d'ora
in poi
ecco finalmente con questi risultati
tecnici e con l'organizzazione di
competizioni internazionali
siamo diventati una nazione tra le più
potenti del mondo di questo sport è
dimostrazione il fatto che la dal 2017 è
cambiato il sistema delle coppe del
mondo prima ce n'erano 10 ogni anno
adesso invece dal 2017 sono state
ridotte solo a 4 e hanno scelto tra
queste quattro come vedete l'italia
quindi italia russia bulgaria e
azerbagian sono le uniche nazioni
selezionate per organizzare le tappe di
coppa del mondo e da qui capite che
finalmente siamo riusciti a entrare nel
mondo delle grandi nazioni della
ginnastica ritmica
il mondiale di pesaro delle scusate di
bulgaria l'ultimo mondiale che avete
visto è stato mondiale storico abbiamo
conquistato sei medaglie tre le ha
conquistate la squadra che avete visto
prima
l'argento nell'all around il bronzo nei
nei cerchi nei cinque cerchi
e l'oro nel fune palla
poi per la prima volta nella storia la
prima volta nella storia
dopo 27 anni era dal 1991 che l'italia
non conquistava medaglia con le ginnaste
individualiste queste due fantastiche
ginnaste a giuliese e baldassarri hanno
conquistato una d'argento e l'altra al
bronzo e in più insieme all'altra terza
ginnasta italiana russo hanno
conquistato il terzo posto e la medaglia
di bronzo nel all around quindi è stato
un risultato storico e 6 medaglia in un
campionato del mondo penso che non è
facile insomma da da contenere una
piccola parentesi mancano pochi minuti
peccato che non c'era la rai a questo
mondiale per questo lo voglio dire
peccato ma si stanno riprendendo ora
invitando questa squadra in tutte le
trasmissioni televisive e quindi forse
si sono resi conto dell'errore che hanno
fatto e mi auguro che d'ora in poi
questo non accada più e vi lascio con un
video saluto ciao a tutti è stato un
piacere essere con voi oggi
un caro saluto a te l'ex cesena dalle
farfalle ciao
grazie e arrivederci